foreign
and welcome to another episode of VMS
and end where we talk about all things
compute engine and lately we've been
talking about connecting VMS with other
tools and services uh and today we're
going to talk about using Ides
connecting Ides to your virtual machines
and for that we have Gennady here who's
an engineering manager on cloud code
welcome
hello very happy to be here
awesome so I mentioned this word cloud
code Could you
um describe what is cloud code sure
Cloud code is a set of IDE plugins for
your popular ideas either Visual Studio
code or IntelliJ what Cloud Core does it
enables an engineer to interact with the
services such as kubernetes Cloud run
Cloud apis
etc etc makes it part of your
development uh your development
experience those Services got it okay so
integrate with various cloud services
and
okay so what kinds of things can you do
in your IDE with VMS right so recently
we enabled integration with a compute
engine so what the way it works is that
you create a VM in your in your regular
Cloud console the same console that you
know and love you create your VM the VM
will show up in your IDE you may have to
hit refresh after you you see your VM
and your ID you can do many things you
can see information about the VM your
operating system IP address boot
sequence as many characteristics as you
can see and also most importantly what
you could do you can right click on that
VM and you can SSH right to it and also
transfer files in addition to a couple
of other things oh that's fantastic okay
let's that's a whole lot of things let's
go through them uh kind of individually
when you say you can view the VMS and
see information about them what kind of
information shows up there is your state
your IP your disks your operating system
uh I can go on and on there's a whole
bunch of things that are new useful and
they're available for you at the right
click so you can see them you can
dedicate some of those VMS to be your
favorite VMS if you happen to work with
them all the time things of that nature
it basically provides this information
in your IDE specific visual way got it
that's handy and especially you know
things like the public IP or internal IP
of a of a machine is really valuable
when you're right in the in the middle
of things you're oh I want to do some
iteration check on some stuff connect to
it see how that actually worked
um that seems super handy and then SSH
so how does that work right so normally
like your your classic experience your
creator VM and then you have to create
authentication uh key pairs to get to
that to SSH to that VM or you would set
up username and password authentication
authorization
um none of this is necessary what you
what you will do you would creative am
in your Cloud console VM shows up in the
IDE then it's interesting about the
public APA you kind of really no longer
care what that is because it's a useful
piece of information but in order to
connect you really see it right click
SSH and you appear to be in a command
line right into the Ides built-in
terminal so the fact that a public IP
happened to be something it's really
kind of I mean it's interesting but not
not really necessary anymore don't need
it for the SS H side so you mentioned
like this sounds great all nice and
integrated but lots of the folks who you
know are interested in in this series
and VMS and the like are operations
folks and the like and might have
questions about okay all integration is
smooth sounds nice but how if we're not
using
um
keep you know username and passwords and
such how does the authorization work is
this still safe to use right
it's it's using the same authorization
as your Cloud project so basically the
fact that your VM happens to be inside
the cloud project means that whatever
setup you have for that project your
authorization authentication everything
is propagated there got it so it's the
usual thing where you're logged into
Google cloud and then we delegate down
that you know whether you have the
rights to log into the machine or not
awesome and then I think the other thing
that I do sometimes over SSH is copy
files you know and and you can do that
in gcloud from the command line if you
happen to remember the syntax of like
gcloud compute you know you know sap you
know files over
um but you mentioned something around
copying files right so the way it works
so you're an engineer you're working on
some project inside your favorite IDE
and you happen to deploy this project to
that VM right so what one thing you
could do you could build your project
and then use a secure file copy to
actually move copy the files from your
local environment to that VM and then if
you have a server running there you
could see the results of your work right
away it's not completely replacing your
standard uh CI CD Loop it won't be uh
instead of things like GitHub actions or
anything like that but what it does do
it gives you this ability to quickly
test things you just developed without
worrying about the differences between
your local environment and your remote
environment so again build the code take
the code use the secure file copy to
move it out there and then you can test
it all without leaving your favorite ID
nice and for a lot of you know that sort
of ad hoc situation comes up a lot you
know in development work or you know our
operation stuff where you're you know
editing some yaml config files and the
like you need to move them over and test
so I guess that kind of leads to my next
question you know who do you see as the
the folks who this would be most useful
for well I can see it so if you're
there's many categories of developers
and you know uh assistant people some
people like IDs and some people would
prefer to be you know use VI or whatever
you know editor they want to use so if
you already are liking ideas that will
give you more reason to stay within the
IDE because you really don't have to
leave anymore uh if you don't like ideas
it might give you this a little
the reason to try the ads again
um because it's a really nice experience
when you're in there I think I think
I've been a little more in that second
category honestly
um and partially for really practical
reasons it's not that I dislike Ides
it's that the it's really hard to make a
local environment behave the same way as
a cloud environment so we're you know
the authentication is different you know
um we try to make you know local
versions of lots of apis that you can
use you know from things like app engine
but
um authentication and the latency and it
there's just a lot of differences so you
can never be quite sure things are going
to run the same way until you run them
out there but you know the there's a an
IDE feature that this actually kind of
got me looking into where you can like
many of the IDS now allow you to run
kind of a remote engine in the cloud and
a local GUI and so you kind of have a
Best of Both Worlds and does is that
still compatible with this does that
still work because that's kind of what
I'm really excited about yeah absolutely
this is a standard IDE feature you have
your IDE running on the back end with
all the power and access to things that
backend provides and on your front end
you have a thick client that makes it
look as if you're running your ID
locally so this is again normal standard
ID feature Cloud code is compatible with
this and it might make your development
experience a lot different yeah I think
I'm a little bit late to uh to knowing
this is there and maybe there's other
folks who are in a similar situation
um if if you are or if you're already in
Ides and want to get this plugin how
would you recommend people get started
uh IntelliJ you go to Jet Brands
Marketplace and search for cloud code as
a standard plugin standard plugin
standard distribution mechanism hit
install you're done and same for visual
studio code
how fantastic
um well this was a little eye-opening
for me and so I I really recommend uh
other folks give it a try as well
um and thank you so much for coming
today and like sharing this with us
thank you very much my pleasure and
thank you to everyone watching we really
appreciate you and your time
um please give Cloud code a try and
happy computing
[Music]